HOST: Bladesmiths,
congratulations.
You've made it to the final
round of this competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic weapon
from history, the war golok.
Originating in the Philippines
during the 16th century,
the war golok featured a
straight, double-edged blade
with no tip.
Due to the Spanish
occupation at the time,
Filipinos were outlawed
from having pointed swords,
and the blade was often used for
vegetation and chopping wood.
However, by the Philippine
Revolution in 1896,
Filipinos adapted to
the tipless weapon,
and it became a weapon of war.
It was so effective in battle
it inspired later variations
of the weapon, such as
the British military's
army golok in the early 1950s.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
MATT WAGNER: My
name is Matt Wagner.
I run an auto body
restoration shop,
and I work with metal every day.
I started watching
"Forged in Fire,"
and then one day I was
like, you know what?
I think I can do that.
I'm ready to crank this baby up.
I'm anxious because I've
never made a sword this long.
I want to win this
competition because I've
always thought I was meant
to do something better.
Today is a make
or break it point.
My main concern is quenching
the blade because that
could create massive warping.
This is the big moment.
Ha, ha, ha!
It's fricking straight.
So now that I'm
quenched, I'd like
to take a couple whacks
at a piece of wood just
to see what's going to happen.
[bleep] I shattered my
blade into three pieces.
This is an epic failure.
I'm running out of time.
I'm going to have to start over.
I might not finish this thing.
My plan is to use a
piece of leaf spring
and get a complete sword
forged out in one day.
I'm working on a
deadly timeline,
and I am just
busting my [bleep]..
I've got to get my quench
done by the end of day four
because I don't know if
I have a good blade yet.
I may have to build
another one tomorrow.
You never know.
It's cooling pretty quick.
I'm running out of time.
If this blade doesn't
harden with this quench,
I'm really screwed.
I've got my fingers crossed.
We've got a hard blade.
I am super happy.
Looks like I'm going to have
something for the big show.
[laughs]
BRIAN SCHMIDT: My
name is Brian Schmidt.
I believe my great-grandfather
was a blacksmith.
So when I saw
"Forged in Fire," I
wanted to try and
make my own blades
and just create
memories with my family.
I think I have a pretty
good chance of winning.
The basic shape of my
blade is in there now.
This is going to
be the war golok.
The blade's looking really nice.
I've got the handle set up
for a lot of work today.
The handle's made out of maple.
It's also the part of the
knife where I'm customizing
it for myself a little bit.
Yeah, not so bad.
I think they turned
out pretty nice.
I sharpened my
blade three times.
That thing's razor sharp.
All right.
Feels good.
Now I want to go test the
blade, and my son is joining me.
Ready?
All right, here we go.
Ooh, awesome.
That thing slices
right through.
Feels good in my hand, so I
think it's going to do well.
All right.
Very deadly.
Bladesmiths, to see
what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do,
we'll take your sword
and deliver hacks and
slashes on this pig carcass.
Brian, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Absolutely.
Depending on where you
hit that blade, you know,
it can always snap apart.
Bladesmiths,
unfortunately I am still
recovering from an injury.
So Anthony, one of my senior
instructors from Marcaida Kali,
will be the butcher
to your pork chop.
[music playing]
Nice.
Phew.
All right, Brian, let's
talk about your blade.
First up, your edge
is razor sharp.
It lacerated easily through
bones, through the spine.
The one issue here is that
you have a very blocky handle.
Aside from that, it will kill.
Good job.
Thanks.
Matt, ready to chop?
I've been ready.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
OK, Matt, its balance and weight
is very forward for a chopper,
but your edge is sharp enough
to lacerate into the carcass.
It did chop the spine.
It did chop bone.
This will kill.
Thank you.
Gentlemen, this is
the strength test.
To test the strength and
durability of your edge,
I'm going to chop into
these huge logs 10 times.
Remember, this test is all about
what happens to your weapons
and not what
happens to the logs.
Brian, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I think so, yeah.
All right.
[music playing]
Made it.
Well, Brian, your
edge held up perfectly.
There's no bending, no warping.
It's still razor sharp
all the way down.
Man, it was fun to swing.
Well done.
Thank you.
Matt, you're up.
You ready?
Give it a try.
JUDGE: All right.
[music playing]
Ah.
Well, Matt, there's
so much forward weight
that it actually bent that way.
On the plus side, your
edge held up beautifully.
I mean, there's no problems
with that edge at all.
It's still very sharp, but this
S bend in it, it's significant.
Bladesmiths, you both
brought in some pretty
extraordinary historic weapons.
But in this arena
of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Brian, congratulations.
You are the new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Thank you.
Matt, unfortunately, your
blade did not make the cut.
JUDGE: Matt, your
blade is impressive.
We saw that it could kill.
But unfortunately,
in the strength test,
it took a significant bend,
and it's for that reason
we have to let you go.
I understand.
Matt, please
surrender your golok.
MATT WAGNER: Even with
losing, at the end of the day,
I don't feel like I really
lost because I went way
further than I ever expected.
I don't know enough
about it yet that I
can make that perfect blade.
So, you know, I'll
keep learning.
Brian, you are the new
"Forged in Fire" champion,
and that comes with
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
[applause]
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Please present your
weapon to the judges.
BRIAN SCHMIDT: It feels great
to be a "Forged in Fire" champ.
Can't believe I won.
It's awesome.
I would say if
somebody wants to start
learning how to
make a knife, start
out watching "Forged in Fire."
Just start at episode one.
Binge watch.
[music playing]